alright hey guys I'm Kate here worth the
aj+ debate watch party we're here with
four fabulous Young Republicans who are
going to give us their take on the
debate tonight and their predictions and
their what they hope to see so if I'm
gonna have everyone quickly introduce
themselves all right tell me who you are
and what you do hi I'm Jason I'm with
the San Francisco Republican Party hi
I'm Matthew Doyle Carl and share the
statewide Young Republicans of
California hi I'm Ben Beltran and out of
Stanford undergrad hi I'm Hillary Hague
a book I'm the president of the San
Francisco Young Republicans all right so
we got a pretty exciting debate ahead of
us um Jason why don't you go ahead and
tell me what the week behind us was kind
of interesting we had ben Carson being
called out for lying people afraid that
Jeb Bush is slipping what they are your
predictions for what's going to happen
tonight and how those guys are going to
address those concerns I think for
Carson this could be a moment to
solidify his lead in the debate and I
think for Jeb this is going to be
another make-or-break moment where he
really has to show that his candidacy
can can be strong and can thrive in this
sort of competitive environment and do
you think do you anticipate any like
Donald Trump and Carson I'm sure Donald
Donald notices he's slipping in the
polls and I'm sure he's probably going
to try to tweak Carson a bit but it'll
be interesting to hear what he has to
say this time around all right and
Matthew we talked a little bit earlier
about what the moderators have to do
this time around to not replicate what a
lot of Republicans said was a disastrous
debate tell me what the moderators
tonight have to do just ask policy
questions and then in us then don't
create a have a serial environment just
say hey what's your record on you know
securing social security they went to
trump and Trump doesn't want to raise
taxes but he's going to say we're gonna
keep social security at the same level
how you going to do that so that's going
to be the interesting thing and I think
that's how they're going to separate
themselves from the previous debate I
think the moderators on Fox and the wall
street journal would be fantastic and
I'm really excited I think the person
that really has to show that he's not
one hit wonders Marco Rubio if he does
another good job this time I think he
definitely solidifies himself as
one of the major contenders for the
moderate side of the Republican Party so
Ben Marco Rubio was just brought up and
a guy on our periscope also just asked
how how do we think Marco Rubio is going
to do I know you're a Marco Rubio fan
what do you hope happens tonight I hope
that it continues like his continued on
its good performance from the last
debate hope that he asked the answers
succinctly if anyone attacks him like
Jeb Bush up that he has another stat
moment like he did it last debate cool
I'm Hillary we're getting a lot of
people right now hashtagging feel the
burn feel the burn feel the burn uh do
you who do you think can come out of the
Republican primaries with a to beat
Democrats whether it's Bernie or Hillary
that's a really tough girl who's a
strong candidate I think they're all
strong in their own regard they all have
weaknesses they all have great strengths
and tonight hopefully we'll be able to
see a little bit more of that cool um do
you have a candidate you're particularly
rooting for not yet battle I'm keeping
that close to my chest for the moment
okay all right you let us know if you
change your mind uh Ben what policies
you want to see debated tonight that
maybe hasn't been talked in the talked
about in the debates yet uh I think I'd
like to see more immigration policy
discussed on a deeper level more
individual plans discussed and I hope
that gets talked about all right
elephant in the room is Donald Trump how
does Donald Trump reflect or not reflect
the GOP uh interesting can Donald Trump
out Trump himself is the question right
I think Trump is coming off with a high
right now I just came off a sand now you
know he's he's still hitting it a lot of
people parties actually going after
Marco Rubio recently about his
immigration positions I think Trump's
position on the last debate where he's
kind of quiet and modest might come out
again in this debate but this his form
this is his big thing about economics
and he's a he's the only entrepreneur on
the stage so we'll see what he does you
know Trump's out for himself he's a
showman so I don't know if he's going to
be and well he can't expect anything
from Donald Trump's could be Trump
do you are you happy or disappointed
with sort of the attention that these
primaries have gotten because of Trump
no it's a good thing because I mean
we're having record debate viewership
right now which is phenomenal right and
so even though there's a little riff
raff be going between Trump and other
candidates at the same time people are
getting exposed to Marco Rubio chris
Christie and the various other
candidates at John Kasich and a whole
bunch of other candidates that they
would not have probably seen if it
wasn't for Trump so this is actually a
big benefit for us so as long as the
other cancer acting polished and smooth
and presidential this is a big win for
us so you're the chair of the Young
Republicans in California correct nailed
it um what will happen if Donald Trump
gets the nomination and don't talk like
talk is over maybe someone who's not the
chair give us your actual thoughts well
actually if that happens in that I don't
know if that's gonna happen or not but
if that happens everybody's gonna fall
in line we're Republicans first and
foremost and we're going to support a
Republican candidate but you know we're
almost less than three months away from
the new I'll caucuses in New Hampshire
it's a lifetime in politics and right
now Herman Cain was doing really well
and before that was Rudy Giuliani in
2008 so yes Trump is doing very well and
he's been consistently doing well for a
while now but only two thirds were three
quarter actually excuse me two-thirds to
three-quarters the Republican base
hasn't chimed in yet so you're only
hearing the very active Republican base
that is voting in these polls right now
so there's still a lot to tell to see
who's going to actually be the
front-runner in two months from now call
Jason um do you have a favorite
candidate tonight I really like John
Kasich I think he would be a great
candidate but I also do like a lot of
things that Marco Rubio has to say and
Carly Fiorina as well I think each of
those three candidates bring something
to the stage that you don't really see
in a lot of the other candidates
including two frontrunners does anyone
here I'm getting a lot of tweets hear
from people is anyone here a fan of ben
Carson I'm getting okay we got a guy
think he's a nice man he's a nice man
that's the extent that i would say i
think he's a next person uh he's very
soft-spoken which is a great contrast to
his other competitor Donald Trump but in
terms of like experience I don't know if
I want him across the table from someone
like Putin when it comes like a global
breakdown is there anyone here that's
comfortable with saying like who they're
totally against tonight or in general
for this for this primary Hillary okay
so all right tell me why mm-hm well I
mean for obvious reasons Hillary and
Bernie they're both I mean what's the
lesser of two evils between those two so
I I as Matthew said we're Republicans we
will get behind our nominee and we all
have our favorites we all have some that
we probably think twice about but in the
end anything's better than Hillary and
anything's better than Bernie so who has
the chops then to actually win against
likely Hillary Clinton who do we think
out of these aight guys i think all that
mobility of doing that I mean each and
every one of them and some people have
to some rinses of opinion with ben
Carson and Trump but if you look at the
other governors and Senators that we
have on stage they all could be presents
they've held a very a Barack Obama was
only u.s. senator for about two years
before becoming president before that he
was a state senator for about six years
so that's his experience in breath and
then before that his community
organizers so you have a lot of people
here that have a lot of experience in
government and in politics and
successful track record so I think each
and every one of them brings a various
degree of skill sets and ability to be
president united states all right i just
got a question from chris nicholson if
you had to pick would you rather have
Sanders or Clinton as president if
that's how the cookie crumbled who would
you pick I think I'd move to Canada
anybody else Bernie or Clinton
I'd also move but somewhere warmer than
Canada it that's it that's why we have a
primary system that's waiver to party
system so that ain't gonna happen
actually so I I think we're gonna
support whoever Republican can it's
going to be and we'll see what happens
next November I was on another question
in there that was who's the dark horse
tonight if there is anyone may be
Hillary if you can think of that still
has yet to shine well I think we need
say dark horse everyone automatically
thinks Trump and they they like to use
him for that and you know he brings
viewers in and he's controversial but as
far as dark horse in any other guard is
character or track record I think
they're all pretty upstanding people and
candidates are there any um then let me
ask you are there any things that you're
tired of hearing is a young Republican
so like you know you're at Stanford
you're a young student are people in on
the campus discussing these elections
and like what are you tired of hearing
from them when it comes to like your
viewpoint right um people definitely are
discussing them uh I guess there's a lot
of talk about income inequality that's a
big thing that's a big reason why a lot
of people aren't Republicans because
they don't agree with that those
policies that Republicans generally push
um and I'd like to see like more tacos I
guess different issues I guess
especially at Stanford um yeah but just
I'd like to say Canada discussion on
policy today especially all right last
questions it's starting one word
describing how you're feeling tonight
I'm feeling really excited I am looking
forward to hearing what the candidates
have to say and maybe they'll be some
fireworks optimistic excited looking
forward to I'm also excited I'm also
optimistic everything about
I Here I am alright guys thanks for
tuning in tune in every commercial break
we're going to be periscoping and
talking to our young republicans they're
excited they're optimistic let's watch
the debate will talk to you guys
okay we're back at commercial break
number one and we are joined by one new
young Republican I'm gonna introduce you
guys to him right
as who you are and what you're about
Jonathan Madison with the Young
Republicans I'm the northern regional
vice chair of the Young Republicans
happy to be here great down a little bit
all right so we saw a little bit I know
you Hillary we're talking about the
minimum wage question what were your
thoughts about everyone's answers about
minimum wage I think Carson is right in
saying that there should be different
tiers when you're 15 year old kid
getting a summer job there's a different
wage for you you're building experience
you're you're getting that job
experience that you're going to build
off of in the future and if the minimum
wage is all at fifteen dollars or even
going to go higher than that then the
kid who's wanting to flip burgers for
the summer before college or you know
for job experience he's not going to get
hired there needs to be some sort of
differentiation between wages so that
people can get the job experience who
can get into the job market and build
off of that and with the minimum wage
going higher and higher small business
owners are not going to take a hit to
their profit they're going to compensate
for that and raise the cost of their
products the gallon of milk is going to
go up a loaf of bread is going to go up
and that person earning that minimum
wage is going to be in that same quality
of life but an inflated market right but
what were your thoughts on I'm talking
about the wage gap is the wage gap an
issue for you in a selection right
absolutely I think ben Carson answered
it best he definitely went off defending
the American Dream saying that the
minimum wage raising it would sort of
take that down because as hillary was
saying companies would invest would not
invest in younger people so therefore
younger people wouldn't get experience
that is necessary and as someone who's
from an immigrant family that's very
important to me to be able to be
employed as a young person to sort of
have that opportunity to rise up the
ranks and that's what America I guess
sort of stands for does the wage gap
bother you and what sort of policies can
address it do you think for the next
president I think it's it's a it's a
it's an issue that the democrats i can
use but it's initiated to just kind of
blankets out there the real problem of
the issue whereas there's people that
are out there that college is not for
everybody Marco Rubio headed real and
you said you know what we need to make
less philosophers and more you know will
welders and carpenters and pipefitters
there's people that work in refineries
right across the bay and they can't find
enough people at these refineries
because that no one wants to apply for
them but they're making starting salary
a ninety thousand dollar your job they
get a pension to get great benefits
these are great things that we need to
be talking about but entry-level jobs
are great for young people and for
individuals are trying to break into an
industry but in the long run that
shouldn't be there major income if
people are hitting a stopping gap we
need to see what we can do about
Retraining them and repurposing them in
the new economy Jonathan tell me we kind
of went around had everyone talked about
who they're supporting you were you
watching most closely and hope comes out
of the primaries you know what I don't
think that I have one person I'm rooting
for just yet I must say I'm pleased at
the overall level of questions in this
debate so far and the answers I remember
the last debate the CNBC debate there
were about 14 million viewers it was an
all time high viewing night for CNBC and
the debates come on right now so wrap up
but i think that the substantive
questions that are being asked tonight
are making every candidate looks so much
better than they did in previous debates
and so I'm just pleased at that so far I
don't want to leave you out real quick
if you want to say anything Jason about
the first little block I was really
impressed with what Kasich and what
Carly fura I had had to say about the
issues and kind of the responses to how
they would help the economy and help
kind of bring efficiency back to
government but also cutting some of the
heavy taxes that we pay sometimes
eyes we're going to turn it back the
debate has started look Ben Carson's
talking yay hit us with your questions
tweet us at aj+ and we'll get back to
the Young Republicans of the next
commercial thanks
alright guys we're back for commercial
break number two we're going to talk
immigration we're going to talk
regulation we'll start over here with
who got immigration right and who got it
wrong I wouldn't say anyone got it
completely right or completely wrong I
think that several of the candidates if
we put their plans together it would be
very it would work out very well as you
saying well I wouldn't say I got it
wrong completely I think that trumps
idea of the best of the best I think
that's great i love that Cruz said we
aren't anti-immigration I think we're
villainized for seemingly being anti
immigration we're not there is an
immigration process and there's a legal
process and that's how it should be done
and you know the more the illegal
immigrants that come in it makes the
process harder for those who are trying
to do it by the book and if we can make
it easier for those people to do it by
the book and as Trump brings in the best
of the best we want the people with the
master's degrees doctorates those are
the people that built this country
people who were innovators who were
dreamers who were working hard those the
people that we want and I think they all
had some very good points awesome and
what about you I know this immigration
is a hot issue for you um I think that I
think that if someone were to get it
wrong it would probably be Donald Trump
just because his very plan seems kind of
ludicrous the idea we had some giggles
over here too yes Donald Trump wrong the
just the idea of like deporting that
many people was just sort of ludicrous
um and then drug bush made a really good
common afterwards saying that Hillary's
plant camp is laughing which is very
true because his Latinos don't end up
voting for the GOP and if Trump were to
win the nomination that would most
likely happen Hillary would probably get
those votes so therefore it's important
that the GOP makes a clear statement on
their immigration policy while seeming
open but still waffle all right Jason
I'm coming to you Kasich had a moment he
was kind of like on a roll for a second
you're a Kasich supporter what do you
think uh you know I think he did very
well and I think he made a very powerful
point is you have 11 million people here
at one doc who are undocumented you
can't just pick them up and kick them
out you need to come up with a
responsible plan and he he came up with
a plan that said look we we strengthen
our border but also we say that the
people are here you broken the law you
should pay a fine out of respect for the
people
came here legally and then we move
forward instead of moving backwards and
keep cycling backwards on the problem um
Jonathan are you gladly talked about
regulation Business Regulation
definitely glad they talked about
business regulation and you know Fiorina
said something that was I think that
resonated with a lot of people she said
the secret sauce of America's
entrepreneurship and innovation and I
couldn't agree more and I think a lot of
people lose sight of that we just
learned up to the immigration subject
you know I do share the sentiments that
Donald Trump's plan of just importing 12
million people without reform or
meaningful comprehensive immigration
reform this is just wrong it's just the
wrong way to go about it I would be
interested in hearing more specifics
from candidates like for example the
California Republican Party supports an
e-verify system that's something
specific that would actually allow us to
track individual undocumented immigrants
and so I think that we need to find more
specific alternatives rather than
getting it in this big heated debate
about deport all of them or just keep
all of them here let's talk about
specific super good point we'll start
with you next commercial break
the debate has started again so we're
going to turn back let us know if you
guys have questions keys them come in
while I periscope and we'll see in a
little bit bye bye
alright we are back with our young
republicans here and the first question
i'm gonna direct matthew matthew uh is
Rand Paul right can you be conservative
but also be funding programs that you
care about well this is a big dilemma
that's kind of going on with the
Republican Party there's a growing base
of young Millennials set you know for
the last ten years these are the people
that have been fighting the wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan and a lot of people are
kind of tired a perpetual war and there
is a cost to this we do want to have a
safe environment we would do want to
have a safe world but at the same time
you know we go bankrupt there won't be a
military to maintain so it's a it's an
interesting question and I think you
know it was interesting to see senator
Ted Cruz go into the middle of it which
I'm sure really irritated the hell out
of Rand Paul so is really interesting
and then Rand Paul just had a moment
where he kind of trumped Trump on the
whole trade deal saying that china is
not even a part of the deal and is
actually quite upset about creating a
NAFTA of the Asia and so he had his
moment and Rand Paul needed that moment
so good kudos to him what do you think
Jonathan like our moment are young
republicans now where do they fit on the
side of spending versus military like
where where do your colleagues fit yeah
I don't think I can speak for every
young Republican but you know personally
I think Rand Paul had a shining moment
tonight mainly because he showed he's
one of the only candidates up there who
is willing to call out conservatives he
will for wanting to over fund or you
know have an unlimited amount of funding
for military support by the way there's
tons of military equipment we don't even
use on an annual basis and highlights
one of the dysfunctions with regard to
our budget and very few conservatives or
Democrats are willing to port point2 in
our military spending so I think that I
think I personally think the bed
Jody of Millennials are willing to say
hey let's cut a little bit from our
budget from our military if it's not
going to affect our safety here in
national we just got to correct a
question saying do you believe any of
the candidates actually have a
mathematically sound tax plan I think
the devil is always in the details I
think that they have a lot of people
working for them to actually create a
good tax plan I think the best plan is
probably gonna come from Carly Fiorina
when it comes for budgeting she says
let's look at where every dollar comes
from and where every dollar goes and
that's actually a pretty sound plans
what a lot of businesses do has anyone
here had a moment yet where they heard
someone and been like oh yeah like I
didn't think about or like that guys
talked about me or are you guys just
kind of second around your your
candidate lines I'm open and I think
everybody's doing a pretty good job i'm
really liking Carly I knew partly was
could do a lot of stuff about zero based
budgeting and indexing the budget
between population growth and inflation
she's actually offering a lot of you
know wonkish stuff so was Kasich and so
it was Rand Paul about making government
the smallest government he offered a lot
of good ideas and I think this is the
difference between the previous debate
in this debate where there's a lot of
interesting policy discussions and it's
separating some of the other candidates
on the dais right now where they talk
big but they're not offering any
substance yeah then if you were a
president what would you cut they were
talked about cutting things across the
board like one percent is there
something that you would what program or
or IRS what would you cut if you were
right um me specifically actually don't
know what I would cut that's a pretty
broad question I think I'd like how to
look into a lot more I don't think I've
done enough research but I do agree that
definitely government spending should be
cut and there should be some agencies
cut as well before what are your
thoughts on what you heard so far
Hillary or at that last tax plan reform
regulation definitely needs to be
reformed there's a lot of areas where
like Cruz said and like Carly said there
needs to be more accountability I liked
Carly's point that every dollar needs to
be accounted for we need to be looking
closer to see where things are being
spent why
and pulling that in reining it in
is and we're going to turn it back to
the debate will catch you guys at the
next commercial break thank you
gangster all right guys yeah thanks for
joining us if you're just tuning in AJ
Plus has assembled a group of fabulous
Young Republicans from all across the
bay area here in California to join us
so we'll start it right off been there
was a word cloud that popped up that
said what the GOP is most concerned
about and the biggest word on the screen
was Homeland Security does that jive
with what you feel like is your biggest
concern with the with the Republican
Party uh we're just like I guess it was
like what are the gops concerns for the
future yeah right um I definitely say
that would agree that our problems
abroad are are pretty large I mean
there's the Republicans were listing off
all of our enemies abroad and it was
just interesting to hear the Republicans
who sort of hash out their differences
based on like Rand Paul saying we should
sort of draw back other candidates
saying that we should push forward um
Fiorina adamantly saying that we need a
strongest military in the world Fiorina
definitely was vocal in this segment so
it's just pretty interesting I think
personally that it is a big issue but I
wouldn't say it's like the biggest issue
is your big word cloud what's your
biggest word in the word cloud if I
think I don't remember seeing it but I
probably would say economy cool awesome
what about you what are your thoughts
about the military Hillary what they
talked about I thought the homeland
security word and the world cloud was
pretty right on they all had some
differing views on the military Jeb
thought that we should be a world leader
Trump thought we should be we shouldn't
be the World Police which I agree but
Carly I think she was right in saying
that we need to be strong and we need to
be seen as strong and everyone needs to
know it awesome uh what else tell me
what you guys are thinking about what
you we heard I think Trump's really
heard himself again with women I telling
basically you know Kay said she was rude
and interrupting a lot of people too and
then just to call her out specifically I
think it's also because her and ran have
now figured out how to on Trump Trump
and basically what Carly did it by
paying him a compliment to take the way
the conversation away from him and ran
just called them out on the facts and I
think the GOP candidates
we figured out the ones that are good at
debating know that but the way he
handled Carly I can tell there's a lot
of people that female support there's
cringed at that moment yeah Hillary and
I both kind of look sure they're like oh
she keeps interrupting I'm definitely
really stepped in it tonight and I think
his poll numbers will probably reflect
that too what do you mean step stepped
into I think he's really stepped in it
you know people have called them out and
he's made remarks that have offended
people and you know Rand Paul made him
look like a fool when he said you know
this agreement doesn't even bulk China
and he was silent what do you think
Jonathan you think Trump has what can
trump do to lose support it doesn't seem
like anything has worked so far well I
think he's doing that for himself you
know as you can see it in this debate so
far he's just said some things and he's
done some things that were just outright
disrespectful I think the difference now
and the difference now between before is
that a lot of people are actually
calling them out and you see some
candidates that are doing in the right
way so
we're back so we'll see you guys a
little bit tweet us your questions by e
I could never figure out and throw this
off
we are back with our young republicans
and we're gonna start with Hillary who
just offered to describe dodd-frank
because I'm not even sure if I know what
that is there we go okay I was just
gonna say that I work for a bank I don't
work for one of the big banks I work for
the smaller banks and I know firsthand
what they're talking about with the
regulation of dodd-frank and how it's
very restrictive and it's it's causing a
lot of problems for the smaller banks
that aren't the ones who caused this
problem and like Carly said it was a
problem created by the government and
now they're trying to fix it but they're
fixing it the wrong way and there's an
it's not about restrictions it's not
about more regulations and they're going
about it backwards and I think that they
all had some good points I thought Jeb
with the sustainable growth of the
economy I think that was good point and
Carly Carly's pretty dead-on right now I
just got someone who said Carly made no
sense she just is saying explain to I
think that Carly Paula I think that
Carly made sense in the fact that she's
talking about how dodd-frank's is very
restrictive on banks and like Trump
mentioned like Jeb mentioned they're not
the big banks it's not be of a it's not
Wells Fargo it's not the ones that kind
of got us in the sticky situation so to
put these regulations on smaller banks
that are doing the small business loans
and the home loans it's it's
misdirection it's it's not where it
should be aimed cool anyone else haven't
thought about all the bank regulation
talk well i think you know i carly may
made a very important point is we've
created all of these news agencies and
all these new rules but we haven't
really seen them affecting anything
positively we just see a lot of money
being spent on lawyers and accountants
in order to comply with new rules and
quite frankly i don't want an unelected
bureaucracy going through my personal
records to detect fraud or whatever they
kind of think might be fraud cool um
what are you guys as networks talking
about right now you guys are a lot of
you are on your phones during the debate
are you guys what are you hearing from
your fellow younger
looking who's kind of winning right now
or do you think who are they saying so
they're saying it's Rubio Cruz and then
furia actually are the ones that are
seeming to do really well Kasich seems
to be kind of like a pit bull and he's
going after too many things and he's big
he's very wonkish and that's and he's
kind of getting lost in the weeds and
Rand Paul is made to come back and so is
Jeb that's what the two comeback kids
are people are saying about you're
nodding Jonathan what he said absolutely
I concur but back on the dodd-frank
issue when I was in DC I worked in the
financial services committee one of the
issues was how to kind of take apart
dodd-frank's but it makes sense for
small businesses and one of the things
Carly Fiorina alluded to this but you
know Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac were
only part of the problem a large part of
the problem was started by the federal
government that's true but I think a
bigger issue is just understanding how
the government makes these bigger
businesses basically more wealthy and it
leaves a lot of the regular people
hanging out to dry they call it a jobs
bill on Capitol Hill for the lobbyists
and the lawyers because they get to be
employed because nobody understands
dodd-frank and how it works you know so
I think that's the point I think that's
funny right then we'll start you next
time and we are
turn it back to the debate uh stay tuned
at the next commercial thanks guys I
okay and we're back um there's a little
bit of climate change talks I'm going to
turn it over and ask some of our young
republicans what they thought about some
of the viewpoints just shared about
climate did you Matthew um it was kind
of like a Rand Paul's kind of take was
kind of moderate it was like there's
environment but there's also economy
does that fit in line with your
viewpoint I think so in a lot of the
wires here in the state of California
especially with a lot of Millennials
here in the there in the valley in San
Francisco there's concern about climate
change but there also has to be a
balanced approach and the president's
take on it hasn't been too balanced and
I think grants / position was great and
I think the other big thing would hear
that I was resonating a lot was
innovation innovation has been a word
that's been used consistently in this
debate which i think is fantastic I've
watched the two prior debates with the
Democrats or the form and they never
talk about innovation and creativity and
technology and how can we grow our way
of certain problems and I like the fact
that our party's talking about that and
that focusing on that one word yeah and
what do you think are you feeling like
the policies being discussed this debate
this time around uh like everything I
feel like there's definitely more
concrete details being sort of hashed
out up there definitely being like being
able to discuss their plans a lot more I
definitely agree with a Matthew about
innovation coming from Stanford where
that's said almost every single day to
us in dorms like by speakers innovation
innovation entrepreneurship it's good to
hear that the GOP is sort of preaching
that as well and sort of telling us that
that's the key to the future which is
something I don't feel the Democrats
have addressed as much yeah anybody else
have any thoughts about the yeah you
gotta say something absolutely i first
have to say I'm proud of Rand Paul for
acknowledging that climate change
climate change exists there's a lot of
people in our party that still can't
come to terms with that I think his
answer reflects the evolution of our
perspective on climate change as a party
and in the Young Republicans as Matt del
carlo said so I'm proud of his answer I
do think it requires a balanced approach
I think there's still a debate about
what a balanced
which means but we want to get
businesses involved and it can't just be
the government creating all these
burdens on businesses that the last
thing I would say it also requires a
closer look at the science behind it
because some people exaggerate certain
things we know that for a fact so yeah
yeah and Jason what do you think about
um young Millennials or Millennials that
are Republicans are your views lining
more with certain candidates tonight
versus maybe like the old-school sort of
GOP stance I think yes and no I think
Jeb made a really powerful point about
innovation and how the energy sector has
created a lot of jobs but it's also help
reduce carbon emissions and yeah it was
a brilliant answer about how we can use
innovation to actually help the
environment without also hurting jobs
like the current administration is done
a turning back for closing arguments or
closing statements so we'll turn to that
and we'll see you guys soon bye II froze
my phone again and the history
alright if you guys are still with us
after almost two and a half hours we're
going to just close it out with final
thoughts from our young republicans get
a sense of how the night went and who
they thought did the best are you with
Hillary um who do you think stood out
tonight they all stood out it just
depends on the topics they're all very
passionate when it comes to their
certain key point and it's hard to pick
one I love the closing statements
because they're really inspiring you
really see their character and how much
they love this country they all talked
about restoring this country or storing
our economy or storing our character and
our position as a world leader and how
we need to win this election and that's
the most important thing then what do
you think who did well tonight I think
personally fear in it purina did the
best um best exemplified like her
closing statement just sort of
encapsulated everything she was sort of
going at it but she was staying
substantial at the same time and she was
just vocal and I just really liked was
coming from her I know Matthew we had
talks about you look at someone being
successful as someone who's improved
debates a debate did anyone on stage
improve I think the two candidates that
have improved were Rand Paul and bush
they Bush needed to do better and he did
perform better and so did ran ran was
slipping ran had a you know very
aggressive campaign over the last couple
months and it's kind of fizzled out both
of them have done very well in this
debate how did ben Carson do we're
getting someone asking about ben Carson
I actually think that he was very
underwhelming and he might actually lose
of it from from this I know he has a lot
of strong support from evangelicals but
he really underwhelmed in this in this
debate and really didn't bring anything
new to the table I thought and how did
the moderator suit does anyone want to
talk about like how the debate was run
was there I thought there was a little
difficult to you about kind of holding
him controlling the candidates there was
interruptions but overall the substance
of the questions were far better than
the last debate compared to the
Democratic forum I mean it was night and
day I mean you actually learned about
policy positions you learned who had
substance and grad knowledge about the
various issues the big one was Rand Paul
you know basically talking about the
free trade in Asia
and he got called it he called out Trump
on that and actually none of the other
candidates called him out on the whole
China issue China was not part of that
trade deal and ran that's how ran was
able to capture the mic away from Trump
on that mood out Trump Trump what one
thing I kind of noticed was I felt like
it was a more nuanced to be like the
politicians were able to like really
state their opinion and not just like go
super right and when cheers and applause
does anyone else have that Senate
similar take on it I think that there's
a big difference between this debate in
the first debate I think the first
debate they're really just trying to
throw their name out there it was a lot
of fluff this they really got down to
the policy there's also you know far
fewer of them than the first debate so I
think that they were able to kind of
elbow elbow their way in a little bit
more but it was no policy oriented it
felt more genuine and it just it was was
much better and it's greatly improved
and who's the next to go like who's goes
get if they're gonna kick off someone
who's unsuccessful right now who's not
winning votes it depends on how well
Christy did I heard Chris he did pretty
well on the second debate or the earlier
debate so if he can improve his record
and is basically his polling numbers in
New Hampshire he will be back in no it's
hard to say it's still so early we're
still two and a half months away from
Iowa and New Hampshire so it's really
early it's hard to tell yeah I think
you'll see some of the top three you
sort of Lucy I think you'll see Carson
and Trump lose some steam as well as
crews and I think you'll see some other
people start to pick up a little more
steam as well all right I mean it's been
a long night so this will be my last
question unless you guys have other
things you want to say let's start with
Hillary dream ticket president vice
president right now who would it be
that's way too hard Super Man and
Captain America we their you harder here
folks super-pan Catherine area there's
so much more to be seen and heard from
all the candidates you know two months
two and a half months from now that's a
long road there's there's so much more
to learn and I find the the debates to
be very enlightening because you hear
more tonight we are a lava or about
policy and opinion
there wasn't as much fighting so I it's
too early for me to say the ideal ticket
but it's getting closer all right does
anyone have an ideal ticket ideal ticket
I think I think Rubio Carson something
is putting Carson in a vice president
spot would allow him not to actually do
too much damage if you were elected and
Rubio could definitely get that moderate
america vote so I think that's a pretty
balanced ticket in terms of like far far
right America and sort of getting the
modern American I won't give you a group
but i would say a group i think it's
gonna the primary system benefits the
moderates so i think Cruz is going to do
better once we go to the southern
primaries but I think overall the final
three or four is going to be Kasich Bush
Rubio and maybe christie okay all right
do you disagree because I think Fiorina
does have very good hearing I throw
Fiorina yeah yeah I definitely see her
as either a vice president or a very
strong cabinet official and I see Rubio
probably being a very strong vice
presidential candidate it's not the
actual candidate so we're all clear that
Trump is on no one's dream ticket or
maybe we don't think I don't like you
know he spent so much money they spent
very little money on building
infrastructure in the end who's going to
drag bodies to go to Iowa caucuses and
the cold frigid weather and same thing
in New Hampshire it's knocking on doors
it's calling up people and that takes
money and infrastructure and paying for
campaign staff and he can't just do it
on a dime so that's where Trump he brags
about how he hasn't spent that much
money but that's also indicative of them
not having enough foot soldiers to help
them win the battle final thoughts
anybody on the debate on the night I
think it's going to be a really exciting
as election season here I'm really three
months I think you're going to see a lot
of very interesting stuff come out
I'm excited I think this is it's good
we're betting their candidates we're
honing their skills it's like a fighter
you have to be constantly in the gym
working out and like we talked earlier
they're upping their game and I want to
see that I want to see a hunger in a
fight because you know what Hillary's
can be tough to beat yeah I'm pretty
happy i guess and any GOP candidate that
makes it out of this it's gonna be way
better we're more prepared than Hillary
as it is a hillary-bernie contest any
GOP candidate will be very well prepared
some very happy to think about that
final thoughts last word final thought
we need to win the selection I'm happy
that we actually have so many people
that are so passionate about this that
about being president about being the
representative of our party I'd rather
have people fighting tooth and nail to
be our representative and to do good
work then to have one candidate up there
that were not fully behind and I think
anyone is going to be better than
Hillary and Bernie and all of our
candidates would be great oh alright
well thank you to all of our young
republicans who came all the way out
here and SAT with us and hate center yes
all of aj applauding you guys you
guys have been here I just like to say
for anyone who tuned in thanks for
watching and follow us on at aj+ on
twitter like us on Facebook and follow
our election coverage while we crash the
party right